le cours du baril de pétrole ne cessait
de grimper ces derniers mois il s'est
littéralement envolé depuis le
déclenchement de la guerre résultats +
47 % en trois mois et le prix à la pompe
sans fait durement ressentir sur un
plein ouest ça fait bien
ça fait un choc alors du coup bah j'ai
pris que 50 euros va être obligé de me
débrouiller on va s'ajuster quoi l'âge
était pas censé faire le plein de
mélange de faits donc voilà pas encore
prêt
sachant que ça va augmenter
certains distributeurs de carburant
assurent que leur prix d'achat déjà
augmenté de 10 centimes ces derniers
jours la hausse pour les clients
pourraient donc être encore plus brutale
la semaine prochaine l'inquiétude gagne
également d'autres secteurs d'activité à
commencer par l'agriculture directement
impactées par la hausse des matières
premières la russie exporte massivement
vers l'europe des céréales comme le blé
la l'aliment à l'instant t elle est à
330 euros tonne ce qui est déjà énorme
l'année dernier althea 240 à la même
époque sauf que là il nous parle de 400
euros voire plus de la tonne donc face
est invraisemblable pour rapports déjà
glanées dans le rouge total fin je sais
pas où on va quoi l'automobile les
cosmétiques et l'aéronautique sont
d'autres branches particulièrement
affectées suite à l'interdiction de
survol du territoire us pour les
compagnies aériennes de 36 pays les
avions direction de l'asie doivent
désormais emprunter de nouvelles routes
pour contourner le pays au moins deux
heures de voyages supplémentaires et le
prix des billets devraient rapidement en
faire les frais cette hausse des coûts
d'exploitation des avions parce qu'on
consomme plus de carburant parce qu'on
va payer plus de taxes d'aéroport plus
de taxes d'atterrissage plus de taxes de
survol savoir un coût qui pour les
compagnies aériennes et peut-être de 30
à 40% pour ses trajets vers l'asie
maintenant les compagnies elles pourront
pas répercuter la totalité de cette
hausse de coûts sur le prix du billet
simplement parce qu'elle la concurrence
les sanctions imposées à la russie vont
considérablement affecté son économie
mais ne seront donc pas sans conséquence
pour les français et les européens